[Music]
good to see you my friend thanks for
coming over to do this I'm excited man
I'm excited last time I saw you was a
beautiful day in shortage yeah super
trendy neighborhood in London and we had
a catch up and we talked about when you
were gonna come to LA to do the podcast
and that day has arrived that day has
certainly arrived I'm excited and what
lovely day that was actually in
Shoreditch and I came all the way to LA
and it slashing with rain I blame you
yeah the rain was the scene it's already
rained more in the last week than it did
all last winter really we need is good
yeah it's good but just not when I'm
here okay when I see the adverts from
home and Rob Lowe and all those handsome
people in the sunshine and arrive event
is lashing like that's not supposed to
happen
I like how you zeroed in on Robbie yeah
just these I've got him in my mind for
some reason well your mistake number one
was January yeah there's this idea this
like you know endless summer beach boys
concept that it's always 85 and sunny
here and we do have a winner it's mild
but you know it's in the 40s and it
rains in the winter so sorry to burst
that bubble a little bit but we have
some Sun for you today good yes it's
good back on track well you've been on a
crazy journey that we're gonna unpack as
I like to say here but before we even do
that just congratulations upfront you've
made the leap from full-time career into
this kind of social entrepreneurship
community building activism I don't know
what you would describe it as occupation
which is no small thing ma'am is huge
yeah and it's been a real adventure
probably a 10-year adventure to get here
it's not like I came up with this idea
and ditched the work and decided to run
straight headfirst into this adventure
it's just been a slow gradual process
but here I am you know and it's it's so
super exciting I had a couple days ago
Brad Stolberg and Steve Magnus who wrote
a book called the passion paradox and it
looks at this tension in between that
that exists between the pressure to kind
of you know leap and follow your passion
no matter what you know the consequences
is the new hot take which is maybe don't
follow your passion like that's not so
smart for most people do the wise thing
and where they kind of come down on it
is what you have executed on beautifully
which is following your passion but
doing it incrementally and responsibly
because I think when we met in shortage
you were still working part-time and
perhaps you know with an with a with an
aim of ultimately at some point getting
out but not in a hurry to do so oh
absolutely and there's this whole sort
of thesis around Cal Newport that if
you're yeah coming on the podcast we see
and I just he just sent me a gallery of
it all right I'm excited by that I think
he's great deep work and so good they
can't ignore you and the whole thesis
behind that is that actually you grow
your passion over time you grow meaning
over time that certainly happened for me
you know I never would have fall down
the line that Here I am this sort of
entrepreneur and helping people you know
change their relationship with alcohol
when five years ago I was knee-deep in
the stuff yeah you know and Here I am
and I think it's very much that take in
life that actually you can build this
momentum towards you know your passion
and your meaning and it's not about
rushing headfirst into it you can do
this stuff on the site you know you can
create these side hustles and these
movements in and around the day job to
the point that you realize this is
something that I'm impassioned by I'm
going all-in but in a gradual process
that's not gonna put your family right
I think it's not a it's not a binary
mathematical equation it's more like
advanced calculus because you're you
essentially are walking away from a very
lucrative career with a with a pretty
predictable trajectory where you know
you're gonna be making X for the next
number of years to step into not
necessarily the most easy to comprehend
for-profit venture it's not like oh I'm
gonna do this startup now and we're
gonna scale this thing and sell it
you're creating essentially a movement
yeah and so you go well how am I gonna
make a living starting a movement that
that I kind of want to be free for
everybody much like November project or
something
yeah and ultimately that's when we first
set one you know beer up four or five
years ago and the idea that was going to
be completely free uh-huh and we were
too well paid brokers ruie
banes and i the co-founder and we all
let's just give this stuff away we're so
impassioned about our own story you know
let's help as many people as we can we
can and then we realized quite quickly
that actually free cost a lot of money
when yourself and we were like hold on
this is literally hundreds of thousands
of pounds right we're put into this
thing not free for you no not for me and
maryam we got to this point about two
years ago funnily enough and we were
like I don't think we can continue we
can't fund this thing anymore we were
broken again we were broken in our body
and our minds because we've been doing
this around our like very busy jobs and
our families and whatnot that we're
gonna close the doors and it was one of
those moments we got together to predict
the next six months and we've in that
meeting we both look to each other and
when I don't I think we did this man I
think I think we've got to go and we
said look let's just take two weeks off
we're gonna turn the lights off and by
fluke I'd created this really basic and
course let's call it and to show people
how to take a break from alcohol and
give them all these tips and tricks
about behavioural change and it was
really easy for me to put a plateful
component on that so when we closed the
doors I said look let's just leave this
I'm gonna Swit flip the switch and see
if we can sell some of this stuff we
disappeared for two weeks
came back and it was like this little
miracle is like we solved five of these
courses right it wasn't a lot but it was
enough for us to go ah maybe there's
another way to do this maybe actually
people would pay to come alone from us
and learn all these tips and tricks and
whatnot to try and better themselves and
we can create a real business then that
actually is robust enough to help lots
and lots of people just enough sort of
positive vibes in your direction to keep
that pilot light lit yeah yeah and that
was it and then literally I think two
weeks after Pan Macmillan came to us and
said would you write book the 28-day
alcohol-free challenge and it literally
has taken off from there we just haven't
looked back to the point now we've got
investment coming in the front door
which we can get into a bit later Joe de
Sena has just invested a Spartan Race
right yeah I know Joe that's fantastic
yeah so now it's becoming this real
business to do good in the world which
is super exciting to the point that I've
stepped away from broken as you
mentioned there I was still doing two
days a week but it was never really two
days a week you know it's like your
mind's always in it and to the point
that now this is a full-time vocation
this is my job
this sounds crazy this is just about I
just feel to be completely free
I'd wonderful the oil business it is one
corage business because my text and
what's apps and whatnot it's always
going on right that is a real fast pace
full-on type of business it's very hard
to just dip your toe into that business
because when you're in there it's game
on and there's always problems
associated with that so for me to have
had the last what six weeks just writing
my next book thinking about one you know
beard trying to do a bit of the social
stuff and all these wonderful things
it's just a different game ya know it's
a different game and you say well you
came on our plant power retreat to
Ireland that was like what a year and a
half ago or something at this point
and you shared what your vision for this
was and it's an ambitious it's a it's
ambitious to be able to execute on that
and you're doing it and it's an
unbelievable it's super cool to see yeah
and exactly and I think if you remember
back at the plant base and wave retreat
I stood up and said you know what I
think I know what I'm gonna do I think
I'm gonna leave my job try and take this
to the garden hilarity that that was
what you were gonna that was actually
was gonna be your mission it took me a
year and a half to get there well it's
scary yeah you have kids and wife and
mortgage and all of these things there
every responsible person and everybody
in that more conservative world is gonna
pull you back to stay oh exactly and
then there is that pressure exact you've
got a family and you've got these people
dependent on you and you've got this
dream and you've got this passion but
eventually always wins out and you said
to me all the time look when you get out
and you really get the chance to focus
on this great things are gonna happen
and you know and yeah you have to you
have to open that door to allow that
energy to come in yeah exactly and
there's something about setting aside
the responsible aspect of kind of
bridging both worlds of having one foot
in each world which i think is important
and I did that and you've done that at
some point you've got a leap all the way
and until you do so you're not really
putting the message out to the universe
that you're all in so why should anybody
else reward you for being all and
exactly that's so true I think you've
got to show up at some point you've got
to you know literally stand up
be counted and say right I'm gonna do
this you know I don't care what the
consequences are and ultimately as you
said yourself I think when you go all-in
people notice that people respect that
and you start to getting that extra
momentum that you can probably quite get
before yeah well let's back it up yeah
and here the origins day yeah the
superhero origin story which begins with
an athletic kid with a dream of becoming
a professional footballer yeah I mean so
I signed with a professional Club enough
ten years old oh I didn't know went back
that far yeah so I've signed the club
where and what England did you grow so I
grew up in East London a place called
Dagenham or dodging ham if you want to
be part it's not very posh he's very
blue-collar working-class I guess humble
beginnings but I loved it there you know
it's I had two things a BMX bike and
football that's all I needed
and I was very lucky parents together
full-time mum to look after me and my
two brothers just all about football and
I just loved it it was my passion and I
think it was very much it gave me a
focal point it gave me meaning I felt
comfortable in that environment and
outside of that environment I was less
comfortable in many ways but I disliked
but an impassioned to win yeah you know
from a very young age but it wasn't
almost to win in terms of victory I just
didn't wanna lose you know is that kind
of mindset I was very driven to not lose
and even when I think back you know it's
like funny when it's what is losing
represent for you it meant that you know
let's look at the work of Carol Dweck
right it was that fixed mindset I could
not lose it anything because it meant
that I wasn't good enough for I believed
then if you look at the Carol Dweck's
work fixed mindset versus growth mindset
and a fixed mindset being that
everything's in a it's inbuilt growth
mindset being that you can learn and be
better I was totally at the one end of
the scale fixed mindset I was this
athletic god sent down to be the best
everything so I couldn't afford to lose
because it was it was the Deaf now it
just meant I wasn't good enough you know
so and even when I reflect on like Cal
affects work for example it's really
interesting because obviously the big
movement is towards the growth mindset
but that fixed mindset was like fire in
my belly you know it got them so far
really quickly and I think a lot of
athletes in some ways end up with a
fixed mindset to a point but the great
athletes then learn to have a growth and
that yeah I mean I'm asking the
because I relate to this very much as
somebody who grew up with a strong
desire to try to control my environment
whose self-esteem was very much wed -
how fast like i was swimming in the pool
and it's like a life-or-death thing like
it feels so real and the stakes are very
high
even though looking back on it now it's
like who cares right yeah but but I look
at it like this is what I can control I
can control how hard I work
how much yardage I'm putting in how many
workouts I'm doing a week and somehow
that made me feel safe amidst you know
some chaos that was beyond my ability to
manage oh absolutely and for me when it
got really interesting was a few years
later at 16 I mean I left school at 16
to go and be a professional footballer
and I reflect on that my daughter's 13 I
couldn't imagine in three years she'd go
out and dray big wide world and I loved
it right that wasn't work it's filled
you live in the dream especially in the
UK yeah like rock stars it's a great
stuff I remember when you talk about
rock star women but like driving this
was when you're 17 you can drive and I
was driving along the a12 it's a bit
like a dual carriageway in my beaten up
Ford Fiestas that cost like 200 pounds
right this thing had no central heating
you could start it with a house key
that's the sort of car though of HUD's
right and I've ever driving along in
this thing I bear in mind I'm driving in
ski gloves because it's so freezing I've
got run through all the windows because
there's no heating to be missed
I've got Right Said Fred a real like
cheesy ya blaring out on my stubble in
car stereo this is something out but I
remember thinking to myself Andy you've
made it man and there I was you know at
17 and in my eyes I had it was the
greatest gift ever to be a professional
footballer but what happened when I got
there I quickly realized that wasn't
good technically I was miles behind the
other boys and something happened then
that was to serve me for the rest of my
life I started to read a lot which seems
like a strange thing to do right you
profess on footballing you start reading
but I start to read about all the other
great players what were they doing
and this shifted that fixed mindset to a
growth mindset I figured it out hold on
all the greatest players in the land
they're the last people to leave the
training pitch right they're the ones
that actually training harder and
working
harder than any other of the
professionals this is not an in-built
thing this is something they've nurtured
and they've worked hard on and I picked
up on that and that was fantastic for my
career right because quite quickly
it escalated me up the ranks to the
point 1804 is going to become a
professional right now you talked about
this is heart this is brutal we
literally queued outside that managers
office at 18 you find out are you going
to be a professional professional or
you're out right good enough right and
yeah it's that brute of one by one you
go in to the manager's office and I
walked in like a hero and walked out
like devastated you're not good enough
son out you go uh-huh and you know when
I reflect on it now spoke to my brother
about it and he said at the time what I
said to them was look I respect your
decision but I'm going to prove you
wrong and I did I found a professional
club owner scored in the professional
league and done all those things I
dreamt of all of my life and then
actually at 21 I got injured and my
career was over right what I love about
that story is that you weren't content
to just accept this this talent deficit
that you were you know sort of you were
being told like look you're only going
to go so far but through dedication to
learning and mastery over craft you're
able to bridge that talent deficit gap
and still make your way oh absolutely
and it's the greatest gift I think is
reading you know and podcasts I will say
that I think podcast and reading you
know it's a close second now but for me
books of transform my life
throughout my life and they continue to
do so what were the books at that time
that were transformational these were
really like the bog-standard biographies
so I was like compelling George best and
these people I'm sure you've probably
heard of but like who the greatest foot
their biography and continually through
those books you'd see that they were
training harder than anyone else
uh-huh you know these were the guys
putting in the effort whereas to the
naked eye you just thought they were
naturally gifted they just turned up and
Bend It Like Beckham but actually the
truth was they were working harder than
anyone else so I picked up on that fault
right I need to add that to my game and
that got me to a place that most boys
never get to right because most boys
drop out because it's it's really tough
but I think what football taught me
which served me so well in my broking
career down the line was about failure
and athletes would tell you that you
learn about four
on a daily basis you know are you in the
team every pass every missed time tackle
we get dropped from the side you're in
the site that's brutally hard and then
you get told you're not good enough a
couple of years later you know you've
got picked yourself up and come back
stronger from that and those lessons
have served me all of my life that
ability to be able to keep coming back
mm-hmm so you make your way what was the
team you're playing on in your 20s
Gillingham chillin FC so these are like
the second third division these are not
like Premiership clubs but they're a
professional clubs right and then you
get injured I get it how old are you I'm
21 21 that's only one it's pretty
devastating and I ended up in Ireland
actually at this stage where I met my
now wife Tyra and I had a great time you
know I absolutely loved it over there
you know and I've got into IT and the
crack as they say and I love Ireland is
such a special place and I spent about
three or four years there working then I
went travelling around Australia again
with Tara and I arrived back 26 years
old just to stop in London for a little
while my brother said look I think you'd
be quite good at this broken thing right
my brother's a trader for BP so he was
like the big one of the biggest traders
in the market he said look basically I
think I'll line you up an interview see
how it goes and I turned up for my
interview we have two bottles of wine
and that was a sign of things to come
you know I was like this is what this
this life so two bottles of wine at the
interview yeah in the office aren't like
a restaurant no no out of rest okay not
in the office luckily that comes later
but you know and 25 this was just
wonderful to me I was like hold on
there's this industry I can go and be in
and you get to entertain you get to take
people out and it was like sport for me
broken was like sport and if you've seen
it's fast paced you've got to be on your
toes all the time and slide tackles
they're sending off it's just like you
know professional sport to me and and
you know it's something that I really
excelled in quickly very quickly over
the years and grew quite a big business
at quite a young age and I loved it it
was just part of who I was there's an
aggressiveness to it a competitiveness
to it that is different from other
industries because it's so like dynamic
and visceral yeah the trading
environment and it's so work hard play
hard oh absolutely and not many people
can handle it it's one of those things
that it's
and you can't work out who's gonna be
good at it what's in them what I love
about the broken industry you can have
the PhD going up against the Barrow boy
without an exam to his name and the
Barrow boy can run rings around the PhD
you know because it's a different type
of mindset but it is all about that fast
pace learning to handle failure because
it's an emotional rollercoaster on a
daily basis and and a lot of people just
haven't got the stomach for you as it
were but it was something that I
excelled in very quickly but then I sort
of reached that place at 4:35 having 10
years in that industry of you know
having a good time and working super
hard and playing super hard and all
those things and I've one of those slow
epiphanies I'm going to call it 35 where
I'd sort of made it in in that store
stereotypical sense I'd spent the last
10 years trying to get to this point but
I was overweight unfit unhealthy my
relationships were strained you know I
was very unhealthy mentally and
physically in many ways yet here I was
I'd reached that sort of conventional
Nirvana as it were of a successful
career in a house and a family and the
kids and that sort of stuff and I was
like oh I feel a bit I was like a 5 out
of 10 this wasn't supposed to happen
yeah you know in my mind it was supposed
to be angels singing and I was meant to
moonwalk out the office at this stage of
the game so I started to reflect on
everything that gone on in the past and
I looked around the office and looked
around the City of London and saw a lot
of people stuck in that same loop all
trying to reach this conventional place
of success to discover that's actually
really what life's not really all about
and from there I started to really
reflect on everything in my life and
think you know I'm gonna try and do this
differently I'm gonna stay and I'm not
gonna run away I'm not gonna join a
monastery and sort of you know rebel
against the city I want to stay in the
city I want to be successful I don't
want to do it on my terms and that means
I want to get super fit want to get
super healthy I want to be energized on
it be motivated and I want to nurture my
relationships at home that was the most
important thing to me and as part of
that rattle
I know it's like who does that betrayed
her for a broker ya know no one does
that
right and part of that process and what
changed my life actually funny enough
was a book awaken the giant within hmm
Anthony robbing them classic self-help
book cuts up all the time Oh
it's a game changer and for me it's sat
on my bedside table and I couldn't even
tell you where it came from and normally
I know the lineage of every book that I
ever read and it's sat there for months
and it was only after that sort of
Epiphany as it were I thought
self-development yeah I'll give it a go
pick that book up my life changed I read
the one quote in there it's not events
that shape your life but beliefs about
them game changer for me I suddenly
realized actually I've got control and
again I traced the lineage of that
saying back to epic Titus and Seneca and
all these wonderful stoic philosophers
and got really into stoicism and
realized I've got control over my life
and as part of that process I started to
look at meditation and exercise and diet
but nothing would really stick right
because I was always a bit anxious to
meditate because I've been out
entertaining clients and felt a bit like
hungover in a bit jaded I couldn't get
any sort of decent run going in terms of
my exercise because I'd be out on a
Tuesday night for example with clients
and there wouldn't fancy it until the
weekend the same my diet right you'd
wake up wanting to eat your salad and
yet you'd end up having a McMuffin to
get over the night before so I just
couldn't get this momentum so constantly
my mind was saying what about the
alcohol thing imagine if you just gave
it up but it was the last thing that I
ever questioned in my life you know I
was looking at meditation I Rea died I
was like this elephant in the room this
thing that makes you feel like [ __ ]
constantly yeah you know that's draining
your energy and occupying so much of
your time and you have a blind eye to it
and so does so many people they just
don't see and I almost couldn't see it
and I was fearful of taking a break from
alcohol because in my mind is how I
create my business it's how I celebrated
commiserated I fell in love with my wife
Tara cuz she drunk pints when I first
met her you know it was this that was
the sort of world that I lived in and
here I was starting to think maybe if I
took that thing away so it reached a
crescendo or I said you know I'm gonna
give it a go okay so it's walk me
through your relationship with alcohol I
mean you don't qualify as an alcoholic
you don't think of yourself as an
alcoholic I mean alcoholism is a self
diagnosed disease and everybody defines
it differently I suppose but what was
your relationship with booze and this is
a brilliant question and
great time to talk about the way I view
it I'd sort of view it almost as a
gradient if you know that mean at the
moment the conventional thinking wants
two boxes there's the alcoholic box and
you put problem drinker in there addict
in there and everyone's in that box and
everyone else is in the other box there
is no gradient to this alcohol thing and
this is something I really want to get
into because in my opinion it is just
one long gradient everyone's on there
anyone that drinks is on that gradient
it's not this box I'll do you one better
on that one I actually think that
addiction in general which can manifest
in one's relationship with alcohol or
any substance or behavior or
relationships or literally anything that
takes you out of whatever emotional
state that is making you uncomfortable
addiction quote-unquote in in its
broadest sense is a condition that I
think all humans experience on a
spectrum so on the very far end you have
the guy lying in a gutter who can't pull
the needle out of his arm but way on the
other end of the spectrum you have
somebody who is in a series of
unfruitful relationships where they
repeat the same behavior pattern that
culminates in that relationship being
unsuccessful like it's the same thing
right and our relationship to ourselves
determines the extent to which it's
going to manifest in a substance or a
behavior or any kind of errant you know
outgrowth of our personality oh
absolutely and this is where it gets
interesting and having this conversation
with you is fantastic because normally
if I do an interview if it's on the
telly or whatever you've got two minutes
and for the first minute the interviewer
is trying to put me in a box and the
reason they're trying to do that to
protect themselves they want to get you
in there so they can go I don't have to
listen to his message he's one of those
he must be yeah an alcoholic or ease a
so-and-so so I have to be like a an
alcohol free ninja and almost duck those
questions but I lose half of the
interview trying to avoid being put in
this box because I want them to listen
because my message is not aimed at those
people because I wasn't there if we look
at that gradient in many ways you know
I'm talking to the moderate drinker the
drinka who's sometime a heavy drinker
because if you look at that gradient
it's not a linear process you don't come
in at one end and end up at the other
most people never slide over the way
they get stuck in this sort of mid lane
malaise that I'm gonna call it where
they just drink to celebrate to
commiserate and sometimes they drink
moderately sometimes they drink heavily
maybe I'll wait and then they go back to
average Li but these are the people I'm
most worried about it nobody's gonna
look at them and say hey man you need to
knock it off because they're just kind
of doing what we socially approve of but
when you break it down they're going out
two or three nights a week and they have
a mild to severe hangover maybe two or
two morning's a week or something like
that like what is the net impact of that
on one's life well I mean this research
is there now and this is a route that I
don't often go down because you know I
don't like to take almost
fire-and-brimstone route but the
research is there any alcohol this is
awful for your your health you know it's
linked to in over 50 studies directly to
cancer and specifically breast cancer so
over 60 different diseases like there
were very soon there'll be a time when
it is there's no safe limit around
alcohol so you've got all this midline
midline people let's say that a moderate
drinkers are average drinkers they're
just grinding the gears year after year
year after year because there's almost
almost an argument to say for someone
that slips all the way down right they
reach some point of an awakening yeah
something big enough happens that slaps
her around the chops and they go [ __ ]
I've got to do something about this yeah
and that's why you hear the term
grateful alcoholic because people have a
spiritual awakening that changes the
trajectory of their life but the problem
drinker or perhaps even the alcoholic
who can just kind of keep it under a lid
you know and maintain they'll go to
their grave yeah you know with with with
that behavior pattern that slowly kills
them yeah exactly so you've got those
those two gradients they're all my seven
you've got the people that are almost a
reborn and have this like transcendent
experience all the ones that the grind
all the way down you know and you see
that story played out Richard Rohr I
really like he's a Franciscan monks got
a lovely book called yeah falling
upwards it's a bit churchy but the
message behind it is really interesting
this ubiquitous story that there's the
fall before the
the night before the diner and I really
resonate with that and what I'm saying
is the people in the middle don't have
that experience right so they just keep
grinding it out and grind it out and
they're not always gonna slip to that
point that there's some awakening so
really my message is all that these
people in the middle and very much what
we do at one you know be and we'll come
back to that is basically trying to give
them that synthetic experience of what
life is like without the booze again
right because most people don't discover
it and to go back to my own personal
where I was with alcohol I was in the
middle right I was drinking no more than
my peers was i drinking too much
absolutely
but so's the rest of the planet that's
the point had I reached the point where
there was a rock-bottom moment
absolutely not
how'd it affect him affected my career
not really was I in trouble at home not
really but I was still drinking too much
and that's the message I'm trying to get
across because then people have to
listen they have to stand up and listen
because actually I'm talking to them I'm
not talking now to the people that I've
got maybe dependency issues and all
those type of things I'm aiming it right
in the middle this midlane malaise of
people saying look going alcohol-free
will be the best thing that you've ever
done taking a break from the booze take
it from me will just transform your life
in so many ways and people almost can't
get their head around this but my point
is this if you want to be an even better
athlete take a break from outcome
guaranteed if you want to be an even
better parent take a break to mon-cock
guaranteed and even better entrepreneur
and evens the key word I'm not saying
you're not a great athlete or a great
parent but you will be even better when
you take a break from Elco fact mm-hmm
if you extract out of this equation the
dependency aspect or the ism or the
addiction element just push that aside
like you said those are that's a
different category people those are my
people yeah that's me the big hurdle
that you have to address confront and
deal with is just the social pressure
like the environment that is
contributing to this kind of behavior
perpetually and I know that's a big part
of your story as somebody who doesn't
feel that they had a dependency issue
just being immersed in a professional
culture in which drinking was part
persell of how you made a living I mean
oh you've told me this story about like
your mentor your boss telling telling
you like if you're not going to drink
like forget it you're never you're
you're not gonna make it in this
business you finished yeah and you know
I was told on no uncertain terms by
various people and that if you don't
drink in this business you're like
you're don't fall what can you offer
basically that's such an insane thing it
is and I genuinely I've said directly
that by by a couple of people what you
said what the brokers do if you don't
take us out and sort of you know
entertainments I don't really understand
it I'm like well we actually do a lot
more than that and but what's
interesting about this story but that
was six years ago when this was going on
I was first thinking about doing it and
I heard a few of those stories I ended
up leaving that firm not but for that
reason I left that firm just to set up
my own business right to test myself
again to test myself in the arena that
was this you know I guess very social
world that I was in and could I do it
without drinking right and it was
unheard of this is like no one does this
no one doesn't drink in this industry
for a proactive reason to be a little
bit better and a little bit faster and
to fast forward a bit
you know the business that I ended up
setting up was seven times bigger than
the previous one and the reason that was
is because I stopped drinking and you
know just to sort of give you a bit of
the story behind that so five years ago
I say on this alcohol-free adventure and
I told a few people as mentioned that I
was going to stop for 28 days they all
laughed right my one really annoying
colleague bet me any money I won't last
28 days and he was totally right I
didn't I lasted about two weeks and my
rubber arm would be twisted because I
was in this social pressured environment
of being the broker and I was the
larger-than-life sort of character and
I'd entertain and that meant going out
and whatnot so if people saw you two
weeks ago and you were swinging off the
chandeliers and then fast for two weeks
you're like I don't fancy drinking
tonight that's just not acceptable
you know people are like not willing to
hold on it's like why are you doing it
on my turn you know if I'm out with you
tonight I want you to perform as it were
so I found it really difficult going up
against that social press when I made
every mistake in the alcohol free book
for example I can't tell you how many
times I would lick
they get to the bar and I wasn't
drinking tonight like I've made the
conscious decision I'm not drinking I'm
a sparkling water I get to the edge of
the bar and there be a bit of a scrum
and you sort of smell the art you know
the crisps and fill the ambience and the
clatter of the glasses and then through
this or beer-soaked air comes that
immortal question what do you want and
I'd say like with full confidence pint
of lager please how does that happen I
just hear that though because I've done
that a million times like that sounds
like alcohol yeah so I know I view it
differently in the sense that I just
think it's conditioning in so many ways
it certainly was for me there was
definitely no dependency there but you
put yourself back in that environment
and you just do these things like hold
on and you know and I've learnt so much
about you know psychology and behavioral
change since then that for me most
definitely it was just about actually
finding ways to prepare yourself in
advance for those sort of moments
because as soon as I got a decent run
going life just changed beyond belief I
got to 28 days I eventually got there
after various full starts and did you do
that I don't want to interrupt you but
did you do that on your own or did you
have like a program were you accountable
to anybody like what how did that work
for you know so no had nothing and and
that actually is a really good question
because it's the genesis I think of what
we've done at one you know beer because
6 7 8 years ago when I first really
started looking at this I couldn't find
anything for someone like me for where I
was on my stage of the journey I didn't
believe there was anything for me I
couldn't find any wrong where AAA which
is shrouded in mystery yeah you know in
conjuring up ideas of you know old men
in trench coats and church basements or
that's it there's no what there's no
other there's nothing it was like
tumbleweed and even to try and find this
act he reminds me to try and find role
models and heroes your stories one the
first I came along and as you know in
your story it goes all the way through
to those classic I guess rock-bottom
moments so to find someone there was an
entrepreneur or business person or an
athlete that stopped drinking alcohol
for proactive reasons because they want
it to be fitter and faster there were
none literally no role models and on
that note if anyone's listening I want
to know these people are I still don't
really know it that I want to know the
athletes are you
those are the people that have stopped
drinking for a proactive reason and
they've tenex their business or their
athletic careers better than ever
because there's so few of these people
out there so here I was in that
situation there was nothing for me I was
learning on my own I was making every
mistake on my own but rather than give
up I got really intrigued by the whole
thing so I went back to University to
study the degrees and the master's
degrees in all these things part time
because I was fascinating why was this
happening I knew I didn't have this
dependency but I'm still making these
mistakes I'll still crumble into social
pressure all the time and eventually I
got to this 28-day moment which was such
a big thing for me and I remember waking
up it's Saturday morning Sun was shining
the kids were on top form
Taro's in love with me I was in love
with her and I went this is pretty cool
I think this is how you're supposed to
feel like my eyes were bright light it's
like oh I haven't felt like this in
years and what's interesting in my
mid-30s I thought I felt tired all the
time I was lethargic all the time and I
genuinely believed that's sort of what
happens when you get to middle age right
and Here I am at 44 you know and I'm
running rings around 22 year olds I'm
full of energy full of vitality so how
sad was it that I actually believed
that's sort of how you're meant to feel
and it's not and it wasn't till I got a
bit of spice from alcohol that I
actually realized what it was doing to
me in terms of that that mental cloud I
think that just hangs around and this
what people don't realize most people
start drinking their teens they never
really stop and if you think about it
you drink once or twice a week
you're always slightly under the cloud
of alcohol yeah you're not maybe
displaying the classic signs of nausea
and all that sort of stuff like that's
gone the day after you've got a bit of a
hangover but it affects your sleep go
and look at the science right alcohol
destroys restorative sleep and then look
at the science about poor sleep it's
awful for your productivity for your
motivation for your mental health so I
think people again in this middle lane
the moderate drinkers the average
drinkers don't realize what it's doing
to them I'm not talking about all the
amazing health benefits and there's
gonna be so much more of this coming
through by the way that suggests
alcohols are no more carcinogenic right
it's like smoking in many ways but it's
not about that it's about what it's
doing to mentally it's like kryptonite
to your dreams in many ways it's holding
you back is preventing you from being
your best self this is what gets
me excited about it all yeah I mean I
remember you know when it was good
starting to get dark for me you have
this idea that okay I'm entering into
this bargain like I'm gonna go out
tonight I'm gonna have fun and tomorrow
it's gonna suck but I'll shake it off
and when you're 21 you can do that yeah
you could shake it off pretty quickly
but as you progress into your 30s you're
not shaking it off in a couple hours and
if you tied one on pretty good I mean
it's it's a it's days before you feel
normal again so let's say you hit it
hard Saturday night
so Sunday's a wash Monday and then you
don't really sleep all that night some
Monday you're kind of out of it
Tuesday the fogs starting to lift a
little bit but you you're not a hundred
percent and it's really not too like
Wednesday or Thursday that you actually
feel like okay like now I feel like how
I'm supposed to feel and then it's
Friday
you're literally working to your
capacity one day a week yeah so and
that's just that's not yeah that's just
like one hard night out exactly this is
the point that people are missing
constantly right so then you go back
into the city and then you realize that
people are just underperforming all the
time but they don't realize you know I
describe it a bit like a cuckoo in the
nest it's off gets its way into your
life and you don't really notice it its
effects are so subtle but you're not
quite as motivated anymore you're not
quite as energized you know you haven't
got that sort of mojo or that brightness
in your eyes but it's so subtle you
don't really notice a bit like I was
saying a minute ago I just fall that's
how you're supposed to feel but then you
get people to remove it or take a
challenge for example and they have
these sort of you Rica moments as I sort
of mentioned almost a similar moment to
when you hit the sort of rock bottom
that you just go oh that's how I'm
supposed to feel and that's why we see
these masses trem for transformations
and that's what happened to me so I've
got to 28 days the social probably to
take you to get to 28 days I I recognize
I must have taken about 30 attempts
right so you're talking open space of
like years so I'm being very honest and
somewhere along that spectrum is when
you left and started your own business
yeah it'll of that experiment
okay yeah and then I came back to that
new business with this dis mindset or
I'm gonna do things differently right
I'm gonna actually set up a broken
business and not drink this is unheard
of I know and and in many ways because
once I arrived there I realized the
business would fail unless I was on my a
game constantly
we'd gone up against all the big
competitors this was a little no firm in
in the UK at the time
OTC Global Holdings and what we did was
massive you know very quickly and the
reason it was massive because I wasn't
making all the time that makes such a
difference on a Friday morning when the
whole of the cities decimated right the
presenteeism is through the roof you
know I'm banging the driver you're only
older a window of opportunity yeah at
lunch times were a massive window of
opportunity for me right because I knew
a lot of the other brokers were out wine
in the diamond I was like let's hit it
hard over lunch let's hit it hard on a
Friday and we muscle their way into that
business just by being sharp and on the
ball because of all the great things
that came back from going alcohol-free
so I get to this 28 day markers as
mentioned and I think this is cool I'm
gonna keep going and bearing in mind the
social pressure is building up now
people are like okay the jokes over come
on let's get back to doing great got
clients to entertain oh yeah and I'm
like I don't think so I'm gonna keep
going I'm just gonna push this boat out
a little bit longer and see how I go you
know I'm feeling really good I'm just
gonna keep going and what happened I got
to 90 days and that's when things really
started to take off for example I lost a
lot of weight I lost freestone in why
you 42 pounds in weight right so now
you're looking really good and this is
sorry I want to talk about what happens
when you go alcohol-free you get all
these hidden advantages that you've got
no idea right there for example time
right with all the time poor it's a
modern-day disease right stop drinking
you will get a ton of time back like for
the last 10 years prior to that it was a
constant wrestle with the alarm clock
every morning alarm clock wrestled there
was no time it was work stress family
repeat and all of a sudden I was waking
up just a little bit before the alarm
clock and I was like oh I got into Hal
Elrod the morning miracle Geoff satisfy
their miracle afford you know I'm gonna
start pushing the old alarm clock back a
bit and see what happens and I pushed it
all the way back to 5:00 o'clock that
gave me two hours right two hours a day
to do what I wanted me time I got super
fit I got super healthy I did my study
the degrees did the master Duke
started the movement or before work and
this is when it gets really interesting
that was 2 hours but then I was getting
so confident because of the alcohol-free
superpowers that was building up in my
ability in the office I was like well
actually I think I'm gonna get in an
hour late in it because I was confident
that when I was in the office I was
knocking it you know out the pond right
your productivity is so so off the
charts compared to what it used to be
comparatively that you can afford to
come later and still still us and so
then that 2 hours in the morning turns
into three hours yeah and this is the
subtle changes that I'm talking about
that people haven't picked up on because
you've got that confidence that
self-efficacy that in your ability
because you're consistent this is the
key word consistency when you're
drinking you're never consistent even if
it's once a week this is why I'm talking
to the moderate drinkers as well because
your diets are never consistent your
exercise never consistent your
productivity is never consistent but
when you remove the alcohol you're on
the ball every day you're confident
you're going to turn up so now I've got
three hours to play with right you can
change the world in three hours a day
pretty much and that's when the snowball
started I start to look at my diet and
here's a great story for you so well it
starts off not particularly well but my
dad ends up having a treble bypass right
and was a walking heart act didn't
realize quite fit guy has he traveled
bypassed me and the free block brothers
all get checked out of course I'm the
only one who shows up I've got heart
disease 35 years old we've got heart
disease calcium score should have been a
zero of like an eight right very minimal
but I showed up I've got heart disease
I'm not surprised I was overweight unfit
stressed to the Hill and unhappy to a
degree um anyway fast forward I get on
this alcohol-free adventure now I'm
flying I'm starting to lose weight I'm
consistent I'm exercising all the time
because I know I'm actually gonna turn
up and not have to phone a trainer with
one of those mystery bugs they're you
know you've picked up this a hangover
really and and I'm losing weight I'm
getting super fit I go back to the
cardiologist the same cardiologist who
just a year prior it basically looked at
all my stats and said you've got heart
disease and you know it's a good sign
when your heart when you're a
cardiologist says the word astounding
about four times in a row because I'd
also changed my diet to plant-based
because I
and figured out that wasn't the best
diet for me which is again just shows
you what can be done right because prior
to that I was the classic meat-eating
salad dodger
generally I'd have anything that was me
nothing that was green you know and Here
I am making this massive transformation
and this this is what I'm getting so
yeah because I think once you get on a
roll with this stuff and you bust the
conventional wisdom right the
conventional wisdom that I'd always
believed was one you needed to get the
career and you'll be successful that
wasn't you know and you'll be happy that
wasn't true
then I bust the next conventional wisdom
that you need alcohol to be cold fun
sexy and successful total [ __ ] so
then you start to look at everything I
look to my died and said hold on do I
need to eat meat to be a man do I need
to beat meat to beef it actually is that
the best diet for me no it's not so you
get on to this role this is where you
can sort of hear there's a
transformation coming because of the
catalyst that was given up how come so I
transform my diet right now bear in mind
I'm a broker in the city I am don't
dream vegans and a ginger I was going
about smallest minority broker has ever
lived in the history of brokers right so
here I am I'm gaining this momentum I go
back to the cardiologist he says
astounding this is astounding again it
looks my stats and says your resting
heart rates gone from 68 down to 48
right athlete fit again the body fats
gone from 35% down to below 10% you are
lean you're super fit super healthy and
he says we regard your heart disease
you've pulls this heart visit he's right
he should have gone up it hasn't gone
anywhere this is like astounding he says
hold on I just want to what speak to the
guy that actually did the test because
he understands that the stats better
than me can see what's going on he
disappears for five minutes he comes
back in and says this is this is amazing
he says it looks like you've reversed
the heart is I mean how cool is that and
again that's a plant-based diet but and
going alcohol-free boobs alcohol-free
the right catalyst to get there well
when you're boozing it up it's pretty
hard to control your diet
we can't you're just like you wake up
you feel lousy and you're just you're
gonna put your face on a you know an Egg
McMuffin because they're sure you know
like you just can't control that craving
for greasy food and when you're hammered
and you're out late like all bets are
off on what's going to
your piehole that night exactly right so
back to that consistency so this one
thing this going alcohol-free is the
catalyst to all this good stuff because
that's what we see in our groups now one
you know people have these massive
transformations in all areas of their
life yeah from this one transformation
which is taking a break from the booze
and again this is the moderate drinkin
the average drinker to this sometimes
heavy drinker that are getting these
huge realizations unnecessarily what
happened to me to the point that I was
firing on all cylinders and thought this
is brewing I've got to share this thing
I didn't really know how I was gonna
share it or what I was gonna do with it
well you're filling a need I mean what's
so powerful about your message and your
experience in your journey is that you
really weren't a problem drinker you are
a moderate drinker who sometimes drank
heavily who by your own account didn't
have a physical dependency issue and
that is super empowering because who
else is advocating for this kind of
lifestyle who stands in those shoes it's
either you know the hardcore alcoholic
or nobody so I would imagine as you
start to kind of you know put a voice to
this that on the one hand you're this
positive lighthouse beacon where people
like yourself can go hey man now it's
cool to do that I'm gonna go check this
out but also very threatening to the
other moderate drinkers out there who
are probably thinking bugger off because
you're holding a mirror up to their
behavior that they've convinced
themselves there's nothing wrong with
and saying hey maybe you should take a
second look at this and I would imagine
that's not always so welcome no I mean
you've hit the nail on the head people
don't want to hear that message and
right back to what I was saying at the
start about the the interviewers they're
always trying they got you in that box
because they don't want to actually
listen to the story and you mentioned
something about social pressure we run a
survey in conjunction with sterling
University of over a thousand people
right 90 at this in massive percentages
98 percent of those people said the
reason that they didn't take a break
from alcohol more often was because of
social pressure eighty-five percent of
them said they've been bullied into
drinking seventy-eight percent said
they'd heard those classic lines of go
have a drink with me you're really
really really really we'll right so
we've got this massive problem social
pressure no one's talking about this
stuff right no one's going after this
this is absolutely huge and what it says
to me that we've got this massive group
of people that have been completely
underserved for for so so long that are
in this middle this midline this malaise
type of place of average moderate
drinkers that are actually desperate to
take a break maybe they're starting to
hear the message get out there maybe
they're sick and tired of the hangovers
maybe they believe they're gonna be
fitter and faster but they're scared
stiff to do it because the social
pressure all around them keeps
convincing them not to and I think if we
go back to evolutionary psychology and I
mean you had you vow on it was fantastic
wasn't it yeah it's wonderful guy and
Robert Wright's got some wonderful books
the moral animal that I love which is
similar idea and when you look at that
stuff it talks about like you know
status being one of these really
powerful evolutionary drives to stay in
with the group staying with the crowd so
it's no wonder that we feel this
pressure to align and and conform as it
were yeah and so much of it is is
imagined or illusionary anyway because
as I'm sure you've come to realize we
put all this emphasis and energy around
not being judged so okay you end up
drinking because of all of this social
pressure because you don't want people
to think of you in a certain way but
ultimately what you come to realize
after you walk this path for a while is
that everybody's self-obsessed and they
don't really care yes they're thinking
about themselves and if they've had a
couple drinks in them already like they
can't even remember what's going on No
so a lot of this is is like we're
projecting something that actually isn't
even really real yeah and there is an
element of that absolutely I remember
the you know the first time I would go
out with my friends and I just sort of
disappear you know on them no and they
wouldn't even notice it was really
disappointing they were like yeah I
showed up to do to press the flesh or
whatever because I'm not drinking I'm
going home yeah they don't even know it
doesn't even register right it's the
same thing with being vegan at a dinner
party or a restaurant you think
everyone's gonna get all crazy about
what you order and then you after you've
done it for a while you
and they don't really care that much no
and this is another point so there's
there's two elements to this it's one
trying to get the message out to other
people to give people a break basically
it's cool if you want to drink but if
someone decides that they don't want it
just be okay with it
so we got a big but just try to remove
that beer pressure of go on don't be
such a wuss don't be such a lightweight
and women are just as bad as men you
know there is this culture of trying to
encourage people to drink and is it
really other studies on that that's
interesting yeah I don't know if the
studies are that but that's more a
subjective view but from what we see
within our groups and you know many of
our members you'll see the women as as
much as men so and they're facing this
same sort of social tribal pressure as
it were so it's just trying to actually
get people off their back we're gonna
have a hashtag break the beer pressure
is what we're calling it I'm gonna just
try and get that going to become home or
investing in just to try and get this
message out to people look just leave
people alone if they want to take a
break it should be cool and acceptable
for someone to turn up to the pub or a
function and so much drinking tonight
all right just be accepted what
meanwhile it's not in a lot of social
circumstances so the question always is
well what is the answer to that like you
know you hear this a lot in the rooms in
LA it's like well some people who really
own their disease and are cool that will
disappear I'm an alcoholic I don't drink
anymore dude you trust me you don't want
to see it it's not it's not a good look
you know it's cool like I'll say
something like that but other people
will say I'm not drinking tonight like
they try to be low-key or casual and
what I like about what you've created
and what you've done is you've kind of
created this exit door you just say hey
I'm doing the 28 day no beer challenge
like no one's gonna say aw come on like
that's something people will say oh good
for you that's cool like it's almost you
get a pass yeah and that's that's our
dream for it I dream for it is that
anyone anytime could say I'm doing one
you know beer 28 day challenge or a 90
day challenge or whatever it is and
that's the reason we set it up and for
me I needed that I needed that excuse in
the early days because as I said just
turning up and saying I'm not drinking
tonight just wasn't enough I needed
something to cling to so I decided to do
one year no beer that was the original
chorus why we called the company one you
know beer in the end because I needed
something big enough to buy me the space
as it were and it worked you know it was
just enough to
we passed and here's the secret to all
of this if you can get past the first 28
days and you get on a roll with this
thing and you feel great and you get
your energy back in your mojo back and
all those wonderful things then you're
unstoppable because then you know what
it's like to really you know have your
vitality back in your vibrance back that
you don't want to stop and you keep
going like in our group if someone gets
to 90 days 85 percent of them continue
and they continue they're loving it
right they feel credit from you losing
weight their eyes are bright
why wouldn't they continue you know so
the key is just to give people enough
space to get started and I think the
social pressure is something that we
really need to get in sorry excuse me go
after because I think it's holding
somebody back because as I say I think
there's a lot more people interested in
than this then you realize they're just
not quite don't have the courage let's
say to make it happen yeah so make it
cool make it comfortable make it
exciting make it fun make it collective
create you know accountability and and
and and kind of create a celebratory
environment around it is enticing to
people and it gives them that excuse or
that permission to give it a go and I
think in terms of habit and behavior
change you're spot-on
like 28 days is enough time to connect
with what it feels like to live in a
different state but in my own personal
experience I'm not convinced that 28
days is enough for full habit change
like I think you need at least 90 days
yes for something to really begin to
lock in
oh absolutely so the 28 days really is
that little taster yeah because it feels
so much more achievable it's like look
just cool and then go back to doing
whatever you were doing before what have
you got to lose I've worked it out the
average drinking career so it's 50 years
it's like no point four percent so
unless not 0.2 percent or something in
saying like what have you got to lose
you know if everything that I'm saying
is true there's nothing to losing it
right again and if somebody says well I
just can't imagine go out of the pub and
showing up and not having a drink like
that just just to live in that reality
feel so uncomfortable well maybe that's
something you need to look at well yeah
right now we're getting to the crux of
it right the reason we set up one you
know beer wasn't really to help people
stop drinking alcohol that's just
behavioural change when you're
at that middle group it's just
behavioral change is not dependency it's
about so much more than that actually
about giving people the opportunity to
rediscover their best self in many ways
there is this malaise of unhappiness
that's like sweeping the nation isn't it
and I think why are people drinking more
and more why are people drinking le
every celebration and commiseration and
to our mind and all these things because
actually I think culturally they're a
bit unhappy they're a bit stressed in
their jobs and I think what happens when
you go alcohol free gives you a chance
because you get this natural vitality
back to really look at all those things
again in your life and try and replace
some of them with vibrancy that's why
our groups are all about health and
fitness and connection people are
missing so much connection and the
reason we created one you know beer was
to give people all of these tools to
actually lead this healthy vibrant vital
life yeah it's not just about giving
something up it's about replacing it
with something is healthy and
invigorating exactly now again to the
crux of it this is what excites me this
is what I do the research about and the
study about because actually what we're
trying to do is give people that root
into that you know the alcohol thing is
just an excuse for us to get together to
come together as a community as a group
and actually learn all these different
things about habit change figure out how
it works apply it to alcohol and it's a
behemoth for many people and the
confidence and the momentum they get
from taking down the alcohol challenge
is huge right so then they land it on
their diet exactly the same way that I
did land it on maybe exercise something
like the domino effect of how it impacts
what you're gonna do in other areas of
you absolutely and now all of a sudden
they're making connection as well we've
like-minded people who are inspiring
maybe they start listening to your
podcast all of these sort of things they
just open themselves up to this new
world because I think so many people get
stuck as I said like grinding the gears
in the middle they're never shaken from
their tree to like have these new eyes
this fresh approach to life and they
come to us for example or anyone for
that matter to do a challenge doesn't
have to be us but it's that experience
very often that is enough to spark all
of these other you know vital
ingredients to a life well-lived this is
huge I think what you said about
unhappiness is massively true and I
think you've actually understood
I think there's gigantic swath of the
population who are very unfulfilled in
their daily lives and I know what that
feels like I know what it feels like to
be upwardly mobile and completely
disconnected from myself and
tremendously unhappy and when I was in
that state the only thing that kept me
going was the idea that I could go out
and party that night the idea that I
would just go home at the end of a
miserable day and go to bed so I could
wake up and do it again was unpalatable
unimaginable like it was almost like
alcohol allowed me to continue in this
life that wasn't right for me but it
also prevented me from confronting it
and making changes and I think we live
in a culture in which there's so much
energy behind behind distracting us
whether it's video games or movies or
Netflix or alcohol or whatever you know
pick your drug or gambling whatever it
is we're never bored we have a
supercomputer in our pocket that can
keep our mind occupied at all times and
you actually have to muster almost in an
eighth superpower to get still and
honest with yourself to live and sit
with your feelings you have to go out of
your way to do that but in truth that's
the only way in which the the truth of
your circumstances is going to become
evident to you absolutely and you've hit
the nail on the head right and this is
essentially what we're trying to do for
people in many ways because you only
discover that I think when you remove
the alcohol and gabem at our nose good
friendly art yours and I've been lucky
enough to train with him has that that
saying not why the problem why the pain
and I think this is we're really getting
to the crux of this now why are people
working to such a point they're so
stressed that they're coming home and
turning to the drug that is alcohol why
are they feeling lonely in a massive
City and turning to the drug that is
alcohol because I think we're missing
these foundational psychological
elements that if we look for them we can
discover them and we can try and
actually do healthy things to fulfill
those needs but what happens is when
we're drinking we just turn to the
alcohol all the time works it just so
bloody easy so easy to come out and
crack
a bottle of wine and here's the thing it
doesn't mean that you're gonna end up to
being an addict or dependent it could be
this moderate drinkers that are going
through exactly the same stuff they're
unhappy that's why they're drinking
twice a week because they're unfulfilled
in their jobs you know the stats are you
know wanting to people and more really
dislike the job they're there in you
know this is so sad your connection is
just breaking down all over the place
and very much what we're trying to do
with money nobody's give people this
opportunity to remove the alcohol and
then reflect on all these points in
their life and then put the work in to
add fulfilled healthy alternatives to
relax it's a relief boredom come on Andy
I love my job I love my kids but you
know I like to watch the game on
Saturday and maybe drink Fortas all
right let's be honest ten beers and then
maybe do it again the next night and
like no harm no foul
yeah I don't cheat on my wife I show up
at work on time I get my kids off to
school like what's the big deal yeah and
that's my point right for all of those
people at the moment you might be a good
dad and you might have fun and you might
be reasonably successful but I think if
you remove the alcohol got even better
you'll be even more vibrant you know you
will get that opportunity I think in
many ways to experience like all the
best things about life without taking
alcohol and here's another thing when
you say that it's like ooh you want to
take my best friend away from me I know
yes this is the other option right but
if you'd like to taste alcohol free
alternatives are brilliant right there's
a lot of placebo in that you're not
going to get the drunk effect but that's
the bit that's holding you back I don't
understand at all I know but they are a
brilliant alternative I think for people
for that placebo early on to fit in to
reduce the social pressure I think lots
of people like to turn to the alcohol
for it alternatives but I get it and
this is not going to appeal to everyone
but my point is this I think if you want
to be a great entrepreneur or a great
athlete or any of these things and so
people are out there they want to be the
better or the best version of themselves
there is no place for alcohol I'll just
take a break just reassess try being an
entrepreneur without it try being an
athlete without it and if you're even
better continue you know what have you
got to lose nothing and everything to
gain
so how long into this journey before you
start getting your master's in positive
psychology like this is when you're
still working full time yes I need to go
to night school yes I did I finished at
the Greeks I love school 16 to trifle so
I had no formal education outside of the
baseline at 16 I went back to finish the
degree I did all this part time in those
mornings when my life was changed right
and the masters now finishes this summer
in June I'm a second football also
finishing the junior oh yeah yeah busy
busy busy but alcohol-free super palace
this not help you have a lot of energy
dispute that yeah this is a difference
but how long so you're having this
experience you're kind of having this
Epiphany I'm sure you're beginning to
share it with your colleagues and your
friends etc but when does it dawn upon
you that you want to create like a
movement I mean that's a leap right from
hey man like I'm killing it at work and
I feel good too I'm going to like
basically put this message out in the
world and kind of crowdsource this idea
yeah a by fluke in many ways um I met
guy really feminine another broker and
just to close the story if you're meant
I meant I mentioned the book the red
book Anthony Robbins awaken the giant
within I normally know the lineage of
all those books
it was Rory that gave it to me 10 years
prior and I've come remember cuz I was
kind of drunk in the pub fast forward to
sat there and you never read and I never
knew him fast forward six years I met
Rui he'd just taken a break from home
what's funny about it we decided to get
together barely minor I'd left that
company he worked for the old phone and
he was really worried about meeting
weeks he was like I'm not drinking a
meeting Andy this is gonna be some big
you know drinking session did he know
you from another car like had he been
out partying with you and I guess so we
knew each other I we were figures freeze
we worked together in the old firm and I
left to stay up a new one and we got
together and he's thinking up now this
is gonna be a big boozy session I'm
saying Andy and I'm thinking I would
have to explain go through the whole
process with ruin tell him why I'm not
drinking we get together we're both not
drinking it was brilliant so we sat
there for the like waxing lyrical about
how great we were feeling at that moment
he and I are just young
yeah two brokers not drinking and
crushing it in many ways
we just said I think this is really cool
I think we should share it he was way
more tech-savvy than me I went on
holding wrote a little book set up a
website and just said let's just put
this ebook up on the website see what
happens and one of those 10,000
downloads later loads and people are
picking up on this book we start getting
emails it's gone all over the world 72
odd countries you're like we just
thought we were gonna be sharing it with
a couple of guys like us in the city and
it hasn't really stopped since because
suddenly it started to gain arms and
legs and we were like this is really
cool we're helping lots of people we'd
get all these wonderful messages about
its transforming people's life it's just
giving them the confidence and the
courage to actually it's about taking a
proactive break it's not about problems
and boxes and all this sort of stuff
it's just like come and take a challenge
just see how you feel so it really
starts to gain momentum and we haven't
really stopped since did it begin like
just on a tactical level did it begin
with a Facebook page or a website when
you guys got together and said hey let's
do this ebook like how do you even
introduce that to the public yet was via
a website and then another website and
then another website as we spent more
and more money trying to get this thing
wrong rise to like it's like building a
house and never actually going to see
what's going on like we were getting I'm
sure we made every mistake in the book
that you can possibly think of and then
it was Facebook very much we set up a
community and we were like what a
community thing work and it's the most
powerful thing we have now there are you
know be a community is just stunning how
many how many people you have on that
page now so we have about on Facebook
50,000 which is really cool and but then
we have two closed communities in and
around there and what's wonderful I
think it's really like the best part of
social platforms right because all the
fluff is stripped away no one's in our
group going hey I'm on holiday and I'm
amazing you know isn't my life wonderful
it's like do you know what I'm having a
really tough day today what would you
recommend would you show me some support
or it's like did not like day 90 I'm a
hero I'm loving you know I've lost five
stone in weight I feel better I'm more
energized so I think you just see this
wonderful community coming together
right from all over the world we have
tons of American emember you have
different ones for a different cities
it's all at the moment but I think we
will as well definitely going to
segregate out especially into the u.s. I
think is the big saw
growth against area in many ways but
it's just a wonderful platform to see
people come together from all over the
world from all different races or
different sexes or different ages going
yes is really cool why didn't I do this
years ago I feel great you know I'm cry
got a text this morning from a guy
that's triathlete Ironman he's been
trying to convince him to do it for ages
he's been thinking about doing it 16
days in because also started you know
the start of Jan sends me a message I'm
crushing it at work it's the best I've
felt in years why didn't I do this like
10 years ago this is sort of what I'm
talking about it's good it's good in the
connectivity like that's a situation in
which social networks can really be of
benefit to people to help them be
accountable to other people to get that
encouragement to you know have a
lifeline oh if they feel alone or like
they can't talk about it in their
professional environment or in their
personal environment I mean the fact is
outside of that one you know big
community most people are going to be
drinking right so it's a solo I want to
hear about it no they don't want to hear
about all the good stuff you're going on
you know I'm feeling brilliant because
I'm not drinking they're like Bohr off
royal drinking they don't want to hear
it and also they probably won't support
you so much so the tribes are so
important in this space you know whether
it's a spa or its club soda any grace
you know but there's not enough you know
I could go around the world on lychee
like botton hand
hallo Sunday morning there's only about
six or seven of these type of
communities out there aimed at this
middle ground you know mean trying to
inspire them but it's so super important
I think that people come together like
that and inspire each other because in
the big bad world you're gonna be out
there on your own but this stuff is so
culturally ingrained I just told quick
story about my book right Baron in mind
my first ever book and I'm so proud of
this always wanted to write book and
it's called their 28-day alcohol-free
challenge right there's a giveaway
there's clue number one I haven't had a
drink that this very straightforward
right yeah I haven't had a drink at this
stage right for four years I've
co-founded a movement called one year no
beer right so I invite all my loved ones
my best friends over to celebrate this
book right the doorbell goes my mum and
dad at the door congratulations
champagne and I'm like
how's it going brothers turn up
congratulations
wine friends whiskey beer so sorry human
beings are bizarre and they love me and
they get it but it's just so ingrained
in our culture that you go to someone's
house to bring alcohol so I've got this
photo of all my books like really proud
of a morph and out on the kitchen table
I wanted to give everyone there
completely surrounded in booze you
cannot even see these things and I think
it just shows you you know what it's
like at the moment you know society is
so engrained in everything that we do
that it will become a solo mission and
that's why tribes are so super important
because you need that connection yeah
well two things first of all the
alcoholic is the only person who will
think that it's a good idea to celebrate
a year sobriety by getting drunk that's
alcoholism in a nutshell which is kind
of related to the story that you just
told but second to that what I would I
appreciate and just want to highlight
about your message I think is super
important is dispelling this notion that
it goes back to this binary thing like
oh you're an alcoholic so you have a
problem you have to quit or you're not
an alcoholic so you should be able to
decline a drink at any moment and it
shouldn't be no big deal and if it is a
big deal then you're probably an
alcoholic to say actually there is this
middle ground where yeah you're not
physically dependent but to walk away
from it is a little bit harder than
we've previously acknowledged and to
just shine a light on that and say yeah
it is hard maybe you're not an alcoholic
but it still means that it's difficult
to say no to a drink when mom and dad
show up with champagne to celebrate your
book about sobriety exactly and I think
this is where people find themselves in
that loop we look to our peers and our
loved ones don't we for that social
guidance and it's very difficult you
hold on everyone else on those drinking
so why am I going to be the only one
that doesn't and this keeps everyone
stuck in this negative loop and that's
exactly what I'm trying to do is just to
snap people out of that that malaise
almost this middle line and just go to
try something different right just
imagine if I'm right because there's
nothing to give up and everything to
gain because if you have this
almost this window to a transformation
by taking a break from boots it's so
simple right it just sounds ridiculously
simple but it's so true I have to say
just for the record that that you know
I'm an alcoholic through and through and
you know I need the tools and the
resources of Alcoholics Anonymous to
keep me on my path 12-step is what saved
my life it continues to save my life
it's my number one priority my my job is
to stay sober and help another alcoholic
achieve sobriety and the minute that I
start to lose sight of that or ID
prioritize it or I take it for granted
is when I began to slip back towards a
drink and that's just me right but I so
my question it my question is have you
had people who have come in who perhaps
we're not ready to admit to themselves
that they were in alcoholic but found a
soft landing with the 28-day challenge
who then realized like hey this is
harder for me than I thought
who then ended up seeking help in kind
of a more robust or professional
environment absolutely I almost think
it's like an early warning signal you
know come and do a challenge and if you
really wrestle with it and you really
struggle with it and it might just be
the thing that I can do it I could do
this is easy and then yeah I can't even
string together like six days yeah
exactly and because it's not stigmatized
it's just a fun challenge right who's
not who's right for a fun challenge it
gives people a little you know
opportunity I think to test the system
and it might be in a low stakes
environment exactly right and it doesn't
work out and you hold on this is way
tougher than they thought it was but in
saying that we have a lot of people that
will come back and try and try again and
try getting and then crack it and some
people will try again try again and at
g-code you know what and we signpost
people towards you know the wonderful
work of the yellow you know 12-step or
smart recovery or whatever yeah exactly
and that's really important and also I
think many of our members will do a 90
day challenge for example and then
they'll go back to drinking this is not
about not drinking forever all right an
absence like Lance is but it's really
because the secret behind all of this is
that I know if they take it no need a
break from alcohol they'll see and they
do it the right mindset this is really
important do it with the mindset that
we're trying to get across that there's
nothing to give up and everything to
gain they learn to socialize again they
learn to relax again all those things
that actually have been missing from
their life they get connection again
they get community again they're more
like not gonna stop drinking anyway they
just gonna keep going as it were they're
not necessarily gonna go back but I
think a lot of people that do go back
because they've seen the other side of
the alcohol matrix as it were least they
can look themselves in the mirror now
and know what it's like to be
alcohol-free know what it's like to
drink and very often they'll go back and
I would have it start to reappear
suddenly they're drinking once or twice
a week they feel tired all the time
lethargic all the time they come back
and do another challenge but this time
they do a year or maybe they keep going
like myself I mean I I never put an end
date on this thing I just keep going
because I love it why wouldn't I so it's
been four years almost five would be
five oh yeah fair but you know why would
I ever do it why would I you know Seneca
said it best you know it's not that we
don't have a lot of time that we just
waste so much of it why would I ever
waste but down a hangover I'm just I'm
just never doing that right and
therefore it becomes easy easy for me
because I've built this vibrant healthy
lifestyle that's alcohol free so why
would I put that in danger by having a
drink that just doesn't compute in my
brain anymore therefore no willpower is
required it's not you know thinking
about this every day it's just gone it's
just off my radar so you've explained
the intellectual aspect of the benefits
to be had by putting alcohol in the rear
view mirror
and you've cultivated and created this
amazing community support community for
this endeavor but one of the actual
practical steps that you advocate like
in the book you know on the Facebook
page in the work that you do in the
speeches that you give etc to help
people figure out how to actually
execute on this yeah and this is really
important so again within the book we've
got all the practical tips right those
like take out the ringleader for example
you know you've always got that one guy
in the pack or girl in the pipe that's
you know if you try and tell them in a
social environment that you're not
drinking they're going to destroy you
right and they're gonna take the mick
out of you and everyone follows so you
take that guy down you've got to take
their might take out the biggest guys
that's an in-person moment this is not a
text moment this is like get in front of
this guy or it's Gary thing yes and tell
them all the reasons why you're doing
this channel
and be open and honest with them because
you get that personal inside watch the
rest follow you know in a social
environment I mean that's the real sort
of light end experiential stuff to the
real deeper meaningful stuff which is
you know it's about autonomy it's about
mastery of this subject and this is
where it gets really interesting and
there was a great study by own water
Michigan the marshmallow study I'm sure
you're familiar with this the
marshmallow study where they brought the
kids into the room the the
four-year-olds into the room and they
offered him one marshmallow right but
just before the research left the room
he said I'm gonna offer you a deal
if you don't eat that marshmallow when I
come back to tomorrow or whenever - so
he leaves the room and then they timed
how long it took for these kids to eat
the marshmallows by fluke because he
wasn't actually testing for that at the
time he came back to the study years and
years later because he's dog stew went
at the same school as the other kids and
he started to notice that some of the
kids were always in trouble some of the
kids were doing really well and actually
looked at his data and realized the
distance or the time that they took or
they resisted the marshmallows actually
was a real indicator of future success
and happiness and well-being and the
science was all over this right the
local field were all over it but who's
gonna defer gratification yeah and it
was like this is it's very rare to see
something in childhood play out into
adulthood so then they latched on to
this whole willpower thing and said
right if we can show people how to learn
how to delay they're going to be more
successful more happy and whatnot and I
think it's misled a generation right
because everyone's been fixated on not
eating the marshmallows as it were when
actually our approaches eat the
marshmallows right come to this thing
and rather than white knuckle in an
alcohol free challenge and holding on
for dear life for 28 days remind
yourself of all the great things that
are happening right now about being
alcohol-free have you woken up and you
feel more energized
are your eyes brighter as someone just
said wow you look great have you got
more energy you know are you crushing it
or work constantly connect to the winds
that you're getting in the moment rather
than holding on for dear life to the end
of 28 days or the end of 90 days so this
is more of the some sort of underlying
for the Safa core type of psychology
that's going on that we're constantly
hammering that sort of stuff home along
with their ownership ownership of your
challenge right when you make behavioral
change
ryan and deke self-determination theory
talks to us a lot about autonomy like
owning the process when we make an
intrinsic change right it's completely
different to feeling forced or a change
is prescribed like I should do this I
should give up alcohol too I want to
give up alcohol and when you do you own
the process we talk about this right and
what that gives you is a bit of space to
bake failure into the pie because you're
going to foul if you look at the science
the transtheoretical model or stages at
range model it only takes people three
or four times around that loop to make
any sort of behavioral change so too
many people have this perfectionist
mindset it's like if I'm gonna take a
break from alcohol unless I get to day
30 perfectly then I'm a failure yet they
might get to day 14 and have a slip-up
or a blimp and there's two ways you can
approach that you can say that's it I
fouled when in reality you might have
been drinking every single day leading
up to that point that's a massive win
right yeah but accepting failure as part
of your learning process is a huge huge
different type of mindset because then
it gives you that space to have a couple
of blips along the way but you'll
continue making that momentum yeah
taking ownership of it is absolutely the
most crucial aspect of it if you're
doing it for somebody else or to get
somebody off your back it's it's not
sustainable like really doing it for the
right reasons because this is what you
want for yourself I think is key and
that's something that you can't will
upon another human being they have to
its intrinsic like you said they have to
come to it themselves and those missteps
quote-unquote failures I hate that word
there should be a different word for it
those slips or whatever you want to call
them are your greatest teachers because
you can then deconstruct that event and
learn a lot about what led you to a
certain behavior what was the cascading
series of emotions or events or
circumstances that culminated in you
drinking a beer or going off your diet
or failing to wake up on time whatever
it is and from that you can extract the
information required to create a
long-term plan that's going to serve you
well far into the future oh absolutely
oh so you've hit the nail on the head
that's it and when you give yourself
that space
we call them slip-ups there's just all
the learning and all the growth is in
the slip-ups mm-hmm no that's but when
you're like I can just speaking as an
alcoholic like it's there it's it's
there shrouded in so much shame yeah you
know they're horrible yeah that there's
pain there's pain in there and at the
time it's gonna hurt right but if you
embrace it and if you're you're prepared
for it in many ways so it's not
something that we actively encourage but
we sort of slip it in there subtly
because we lose too many people that
will come along do a challenge
brilliantly well to day 20 slip up and
disappear and go I felt that's it and I
think when you're aimed in that middle
ground so we're not aimed at the
dependent you know you can say to those
people look don't use that as an excuse
to give up so you all must slip it in we
slip it into some of the work that we do
for the videos or the emails so it's in
the back of their mind that actually
they might slip up and if they do
there's great learning in that it's
gonna hurt and you're gonna feel like
you've failed and you've messed up but
there's so much growth in there because
as you said you can find out ways to not
slip up in the future and suddenly then
you do 30 days a 40 days or 90 days and
the whole world looks at different and
it's a lot easier to get from 80 days to
90 days than it is to get from zero days
to 10 days yeah okay yeah the hardest
new in yoga is on to the mat right so
you've got to get onto the Mariner wine
yeah you've got a that first couple of
weeks is is where all the grass teas for
lots of people here and you touched on
it right at the start
lots of people will get to day 21 I used
to do this all the time feel amazing
what do you do you celebrate you have a
drink it's got party yeah I feel great
again let's go and this is the stuff
that fascinates me this is the stuff
that I'm trying to learn about well yeah
I mean this is psychology so drilling
down on the psychological and
philosophical underpinnings the
foundation that resides beneath this it
it's about identity right and I think
you know we're two white males you're
coming from a very alpha industry so it
conjures up this idea of masculinity and
what does that mean to be a man does it
mean that you have to you know pound
your chest and and be
guy at the bar who's ordering a round of
drinks for everybody who can entertain
through lunch and be the most
charismatic guy will eat downs a couple
martinis and then goes back to work and
crushes it throughout the afternoon and
you know is that is that what it means
to be a man and is there a better
definition can we reclaim this and and
change it yeah and I think this is this
is a really important question because I
think so much identities baked into
alcohol for example and a sense of
manliness but actually even just winding
out that a second women are drinking as
much as men for the first time ever hmm
so I think you know women's identities
are being wrapped up in in alcohol very
much now and but back to the to the
manly question and I think it takes a
lot of courage to step away and not
drink it really does as a man I think
he's one of the most manly things that
you can possibly do is like make a stand
whenever you know Mark Twain said it
best when you find yourself on the side
of the majority it's time to pause and
reflect and I think that's so true
around alcohol to have the ability to
step away from the crowd takes an
immense amount of courage and I think
there's something really empowering for
me to be a father to my two girls and
not drink I love that that makes me feel
strong as a person that makes me feel
manly that I can deal with all life's
growing up me whether that's a funeral
or whether that's the stress or whether
that's stereotypical you know major
trauma in your life with a clear head
and deal with it you know effectively
and vibrantly rather than bury myself in
alcohol I think there's something
extremely empowering by that when you
when you understand that alcohol masks
your emotional state and that more often
than not it's used to escape from
whatever you're feeling in the moment
and that can be like if we're being
totally honest like that can be
characterized as cowardly and I think it
takes a lot of courage to say as
uncomfortable as I am in this current
situation that I find myself I'm going
to sit with it and experience it because
that's the only way I can learn from it
and make changes or move forward but to
deny it or
gape it or numb myself from whatever
it's trying to tell me is taking an easy
route out and an escape hatch that
ultimately might feel good in the moment
but isn't serving me yeah exactly and I
think there's real empowerment in that
and I think that's one of the biggest
benefits of going alcohol-free it's
actually facing everything life's got to
throw at you with that clear hand and
knowing that you can deal with it and
knowing that you don't have to run away
and and and ultimately understanding
that the fear of facing it is more
severe than the pain of actually facing
it yeah you know I mean it's like the
anticipation that builds that creates
all that anxiety around facing that
thing you don't want to face when you
finally just face it 99 times out of a
hundred you're like why it wasn't that
bad exactly and then you build that
confidence that self-efficacy that
actually you know I can deal with all of
these things I can deal with the stress
of them you know what I mean the job
loss or the funeral that their death
without alcohol you know but I think for
so many people it's become so ubiquitous
in our lives that for every occasion
there's an excuse to have a drink if
it's you know socially or commissural
so you know it now even one drink you
haven't had in almost five years and
what would you it makes no sense you
know to me why would I ever do that you
know that's how my mindset is with this
thing is just like look I've gained so
much from this alcohol-free adventure
that I'm on well I'd have a go back it
just doesn't doesn't register so what's
the second book the second books on
motivation which I'm super excited about
so channeling all my learning in many
ways you're not it's like you put
yourself under pressure again and you
agree to write a book and then you go oh
now I've got going on I've gotta go and
write this thing and it's been fantastic
because I think it's very much dulled
into what I've been doing one you know
beer and behavioral change on a mass
scale in many ways I mean you know the
mission over the next few years is try
and reach a million people so I'm
constantly trying to figure out better
ways to motivate people and better ways
to help people make behavioral change so
I'm just dipping my toe into the water
I'm just warming up there's so much to
learn I don't have all the answers far
from it but I'm really starting to make
headway because I think a lot of what
the second book is about is about a
process a motivational process
underlying it or really is just an
excuse to create a lifelong lift it's a
motivational process that you can use to
overcome alcohol but you can also
transform your diet with it and you can
also change your career with the same
type of process if you know the mean and
ultimately what you're doing you're
building momentum towards this life
well-lived to fill these psychological
needs that I think are missing in in so
much of modern-day life and what's that
book gonna be called a common well I
genuinely thought yes in the writing
part of it yeah yeah so we've got four
or five months yeah yeah well you guys
have had crazy growth and you've gotten
tons of media attention so you've
definitely tapped a nerve and a chord
and you're filling a need like there's
the response to one year no beer has
been massive oh I absolutely like the
world over because I think people dialed
in to the fact that hold on well this is
really cool for one and I can take a
break and it's not all about again
dependency and it's it's in that middle
ground that no one's really been in
there before and I think people are
excited about it and there's more and
more momentum as we know Millennials are
drinking less and less and I think again
it's that middle band that's sort of 30
to 50 year olds are like hold on this is
yeah why are we meant to be doing this
right it's the it is the 30 to 50 to the
60 yeah you're also the Millennials
don't drink that much like I'm around a
lot of Millennials and like they don't
have the same relationship with alcohol
that our generation did maybe because
pot is so ubiquitous I don't know what
it is but it's definitely qualitatively
different I think and there's more
interest in wellness and well-being than
there was when we were that age and also
being authentic you know you see this
all the time you know on the social
platforms and ultimately we're not
authentic when we drink and we turn into
someone that we're not and I think the
younger generation are thriving on
authenticity in many ways versus - yeah
and and I think we hide behind it and
and I've said this all along even if
you're drinking twice a week you're
never really you
we almost joke about this all the time
you actually only start to discover
yourself which is the greatest discovery
you'll ever make by the way your
authentic self when you take a break
from alcohol because you're normally
under its cloud whether that is just the
subtle effects of not having slept very
well or the obvious effects of actually
the hangovers or
or actually being under the influence of
alcohol you rarely get to experience
life as yourself and even my story I
assumed I was this extrovert all of my
life I fought I was an extrovert and
then I stopped drinking I went I'm a
classic introvert and you might not
think that but I genuinely am I ready
for news but I want to go to that party
like it's not funny and it was such it
was so liberating to figure that out but
imagine for like almost 40 years I'd
convinced myself I was someone that I'd
she wasn't I could play the part
brilliantly but I was like Superman I
had to go into the phone box and down a
couple of pints and then I come out as
this like flamboyant guy whereas and you
know I love being me now but that's
really hard and edgy is a good point I
think a lot of people struggle to let go
of that identity that person that
they've created all that persona that
they've created around okay and for me
that was one of the hardest challenges
was just going I'm not gonna be that guy
anymore but you know I don't want to be
that guy anymore I want to hang out
around the valla fonts and just sort of
have a nice deep conversation if someone
said I mean I don't want to be hanging
off the chandeliers anymore and for me
that's been the greatest discovery of
all is actually being myself
and loving it and enjoying it what did
you learn from your time with Kara or
our Gables great and so the big the big
learning for me was back to this this
called theme which was why not not why
the problem why the paint exploring the
the prospect of childhood trauma yeah
exactly I mean and some of that is
really interesting and gap I went out on
a limb and he did some pretty crazy
stuff and I was like oh I'm not sure
like on you like one on one no nice
layer just in general ideas within the
game you know he almost joked he said
look if you think you had a really good
childhood but you've now got one of
these terrible diseases I Got News for
you come up here and I'll tell you he'll
identify and I'll say well they didn't
have a great childhood and actually all
these other things so some of that is
quite difficult to stomach as it were
and he's great you know so confident
prevent and he's charismatic with it and
he's so learn it on those subjects and
fascinating to be around but the big
point for me constantly which really got
me thinking about this big cultural
question you know why are people turning
to alcohol and seem substances
on a mass scale that might not end up as
dependent what's the pine points and I
think the pain points are these classic
things that we're missing like
connection and autonomy in control these
are the much bigger questions that we
should be asking rather than getting too
focused on like alcohols the daring we
have to remove the outdoors not that
it's way bigger than that
have you read Johann Horace bucks yeah
yeah so he was just in here recently I
just put his episode up the other day
but that's his whole thing you know lost
connections that this lack of intimacy
this disconnection that humans have from
each other is driving not just you know
the the addiction epidemic but our
epidemic of declining mental health and
depression and suicide and the like
exactly all right and then this goes
back to that box argument so the box
people we can understand that maybe
they're all addicted but everyone else
on that plane and that gradient are
probably drinking a little bit because
they're a bit unhappy you know they're
not everyone but you get the point I
think because of this cultural malaise
that maybe they're lacking autonomy or
they're stressed all the time so they
just looking for things and what's
happening is they're not discovering
ways to achieve those ends without
alcohol it's so easy and it's so
ubiquitous and it's so encouraged
whereas it takes a lot more effort to
find ways to create new connection it
takes a lot more effort to find ways to
relax without alcohol and again this is
all baked into what we're trying to do
it one yeah beer that's why it's so
bigoted well the natural progression of
what you're doing and I'm sure you've
thought about this and I'm interested in
and where you're at specifically with it
is to take this model and create these
communities not just virtual communities
but in-person communities city by city
right so in the way that like turn
around see the November project book
underneath brushing it like pull that
out and then your book is behind there
to pull that out so November project you
see that on the bottom and then your
book is underneath David Goggins over
there 28-day I'll call free see there
you go I should have pulled that out
before in the way that November project
has these city-by-city chapters and it's
free and you show up in the morning and
you work out and it's high-energy and
it's exciting and it's very communal and
encouraging
I can see like a tweak on that like a
version of that around the idea that
you're putting out into the world
oh absolutely would be really cool yeah
and it's starting to happen we have lots
of sort of meetups as we call it where
the members are just saying look I'm in
Chicago I'm in New York or I'm in London
I'm gonna get together who wants to join
me and seeing the online transfer
offline is stunning and and I touched on
this because the group in the community
come together in such a honest way it's
really nice when you meet in person
because you've got rid of all that fluff
again no one's pretending to be
something they're not it's very real
it's very visceral so when you meet
these people in person is that instant
connection that instant bond and then
it's not about alcohol right now it's
talking about how come they're talking
about getting fit they're talking about
getting healthy they're talking about
crushing their jobs so I think a lot of
this will transfer into these physical
style meetups all over the world that's
the plan we've just got over a million
pounds in investment which is you know
huge for us this is real firm this and
that's from Joe no Joe is one of the
embrace we've got about 10 a million
best that's amazing yeah you know we've
only really been you know operating for
a couple of years in terms of our
business but you know that's the mission
is to try and grow a business that does
good in the world to actually can get
out there and I know now but this is the
thing what's interested about this for
the last hundred years has only ever
been one message marketed about come
it's called sexy fun and we're flooded
with all this marketing and my vision I
think for one you know beer if it grows
big enough is that maybe we're
advertising on the billboards like this
the real truth which is going
alcohol-free is cool sexy fun and you'll
be way more successful or at halftime on
the Superbowl you know someone actually
come in the other way telling the other
side of the story because for last
hundred years has only ever been you
know almost one message yeah if you go
to me and if you're not partaking then
you're some kind of freak I think you're
damaged you're damaged yeah whereas this
is the opposite it's like hold on we're
all crushing it out of here by the way
you know having these wonderful time
well like losing weight getting fit
crushing it at work and we're not
drinking you know and that's why I want
more role models to come out the
woodwork and say I don't drink we seem
to know everyone that does drink yeah
all the sports stars that fall out the
nightclub at 2:00 a.m. but we don't
really know about the guys that don't
drink heard like
yeah you know yeah exactly well I love
the book what's cool about it is it's
not like some kind of you know typical
self-help primer where it's like here's
your here are the steps to do this and
you know it's it's not heavy in that
regard like it's very colorful it's very
graphics heavy it's very easy to read
you could pick it up and open it to any
page and you know get some wisdom about
how to you know now forget your health
your day and in a healthier way
it's just friendly you know it's like
you could leave it out anywhere there's
no like stigma like if you bought a book
like do you have a problem with drinking
you know you can't like have that out in
your coffee table but this is like oh
this is cool like I want to look through
this it's full of beautiful photographs
and it's just you know it's uplifting I
guess that's a word I'm like yeah and so
true and when we said to the publisher
at Pan Macmillan we'd be like look this
needs to pass the tube test we need to
okay reading the subway yeah are they
gonna be like pretending something every
war and peace and then they've got like
Gemma in the middle of it so you know
it's bright and it's in your face and
it's you know that's what it's about
it's all about uplifting and vibrancy
and health and being your best self I
think that's what life's all about you
know that's why I'm on this mission
that's why I'm you know chasing this
this path towards meaning in many ways
how's the book done it's still in well
write fantastic yeah and then it gets
another lift so it was out this time
last year but then it goes again because
we have the big thing in the UK called
dry Jam so lots of people right now oh
that's happening right yeah yeah so what
else you doing in LA we are SoulCycle
this is the Divya cycle cycle this is
different you come to LA it's gonna be
like party time we're up in the 6 a.m.
spin class my wife and I yeah Tara
loving it right it's a different well
because you just see a different part of
life you know and I think you see you
make that real connection that doesn't
have to involve alcohol at the time yet
but we have a brilliant time together
right well thank you for coming out here
it's a pleasure to connect with you it's
been growing one year no beer is the way
to go it's supercool what you're doing
and serving a huge need for people and I
applaud you and I
at your service my friend anything I can
do to help you please reach out to me
everybody should whether you have a
problem with alcohol or not you should
check out the book the 28-day alcohol
free challenge just because it's an
awesome book and look let's be honest
the truth is chances are if you're not
struggling with alcohol in one way or
another I'm sure you know somebody who
who is or maybe somebody you could just
do with a little break right that's
really who we're going yeah exactly
they're in the people in the middle of
them the moderates an average drinkers
just come and take a break and if you
feel amazing at the end of it keep going
right does it find one year no beer on
Facebook and when you're no beer Dahmer
is ony be calm
what do you know beer calm okay cool
yeah it's all happening just come and do
a challenge and Jess yeah you feel what
you feel great keep going and what are
the what's your deal with the public
speaking oh this is the big thing don't
answer yeah I really want to get into
the second half of this year I want to
speak as much as I can get this message
out now I'm really enjoying it and again
it's like writing in many ways I think
you have to give it a bit of time and
respect that is public speaking and
that's you know something that I want to
add to my armory is it work just to get
out there and meet more people and test
myself get myself out of the comfort
zone as an introvert you know standing
up on stage and talking in front of a
lot of people I keep saying and
everybody you're sitting across from me
struggling with what to say just I gotta
pull it out of you yeah I know I know I
mean I am though that's a big thing for
me speaking so yeah I really I get on
stage and get this message out to more
and more people cool well as those
things get scheduled I trust that they
will be up on the website if people want
to come and hear you and shake your hand
and absolutely do and if someone's
listening to this and they're like hey
I'm going on a business trip I don't
really feel like drinking I'm gonna be
with a couple guys I know they're gonna
go out partying and I'm gonna be sitting
in my hotel room bored where should they
go should they go to your Facebook page
and try to find somebody else
like-minded in their City or like where
do you point those people yeah go to one
you know beer if you can and on the
website there you can sign up to a
challenge if you want to sign up to a
challenge or go to the Facebook page or
on Instagram and I'm on doing Facebook
lives and it's their lives and all this
sort of stuff trying to inspire people
there's loads of stuff going on
community cool alright my friend come
back and talk to me some more Buddha
love it thanks so much whiskey's a
pleasure yeah thank you
peace plants no beer sobriety
[Music]